[Music]
let's start a
new topic on
the forward edition system
we'll look into the details of the full
irrigation system
the design aspects the various
design parameters which are required for
the detailed design
but before we do that
i'd like to
establish a relationship between
various elements
which are
at once
time
infiltration
and
depoculation
this relationship will be a general
purpose relationship which will be used
for
all these surface irrigation methods
even the border irrigation method which
we have considered
earlier
this would be applicable to that
this will give you a general
understanding that
how these
items the advance time
the infiltration
and the deep population are related to
each other
and these relationships you can exploit
for the design purposes
so this will be a very
important uh
way of
looking at the overall forces
let's take the
caustic of relationship
which we had defined
earlier and this gives
the
infiltration that the accumulated
inflation depth
with respect to
the opportunity time
and these two parameters which we have
defined
c and alpha are the
empirical constants or these parameters
we had also seen that how we can
derive these parameters from the
absorbed infiltration
data which is taken in the field
so these
are basically defining the type of soil
for each
type of soil
these parameters are known
and t
as nothing but
as the infiltration opportunity time
in other words
if i
write
t
i can write this t
in terms of
y and these two parameters
i can approximate
this t which is the infiltration
opportunity time
to
this t here
as we have used
this t is nothing but infiltration
opportunity time
which means that at the surface of the
ground
for how long the water was
available
and for how long the infiltration
opportunity was
prevailing
so accordingly the depth of infiltration
can be determined depending on
what is the time of
infiltration or what is the
time for which
at least that assumption is valid that
the amount of water is more than
the infiltration opportunity
or the infiltration capacity
those things we have seen and since in
irrigation
when we are applying irrigation water we
are ensuring that the depth of
irrigation is always more than
the infiltration opportunity
of the infiltration capacity
prevailing at that particular time
but we can make an approximation that
this time
can be approximated to
the time of
irrigation
so when we find out this time
the t
t now
may be taken as
the required time of
irrigation
but what assumption we are making is
that the time of infiltration
opportunity is equal to the time of
irrigation
so indirectly we can
we can find out that time if we know
the
the characteristics of the soil
this this relationship is known which we
have already
looked at
now let's assume that the soil is
we make
two more assumptions
first
the soil is
as
uniform
that means the soil characteristics are
not changing
for that particular field which is in
question
and
we also make another assumption that
the
initial
moisture content
and also
uniform
now making these two assumptions
let's take that
the distance
led
we take z as the vertical distance
the distance set from the soil surface
to the depth of
nothing
if we when we when you irrigate the soil
when the infiltration will take place
the wetting front will move so if you
want to express
that wetting front in the form of
distance z
then this distance z can also be
expressed
it can be expressed as a function of
y
okay
that will be proportional to
with some
proportionality constant f k
i define as a proportionality constant
of case
then i can
express
z
with respect to y
and
if i substitute
y from the
the caustic of equation
this can be
expressed as
plus c t to the power alpha and okay
now this
these are two constants
i can express this as
a new constant which is
k
dash to the power alpha
okay
let's take two more
quantities
tt is time
required
for advanced curve
another field
time required for advanced curve to
reach the
end of the
field
and
of tn is the time
required
to infiltrate
the net irrigation
requirement
which is
y n
so t to achieve the net irrigation
requirement
if you need
the time t n
that is the time which is required
to get this
net depth of irrigation
and tt
is the time
of advance of the waterfront to reach
the downstream end
now here comes
the various options available to you
it depends on your
type of soil
as well as
the length of the field
that what will be the the value of t
in terms of t n
or what is the proportion of
t t
of t n
which is required for the waterfront to
move in the
downstream direction and to reach the
downstream end of the field
for
example right now we'll assume that
we'll make assumption we'll take one
case
where
we will assume that this tt
is 1 4
the time of
net infiltration
that if that infiltration is 1 unit
will take 1 4 the time for the walk with
the advanced
curve to reach the non-instrument
so if we make that assumption
there can be various cases it might it
depends on the
characteristics of the soil it depends
on the length of the field that
how what will be the tt because the
movement
is a function of
how much of the water is infiltrating
with the soil as the water is moving in
the forward direction and is also a
function of what is the length of the
field
so these are
there's only one possibility there can
be many possibilities depending on
how you have fixed the other parameters
so let's make assumption that
assume
we are making assumption that dt for the
present case which we are going to
consider
is 1 4 30 n
time taken
for the net education depth to be
achieved
is
is four times the time taken for the
advanced curve to reach the downstream
end
so with this assumption
we
we divide the total time taken
which is the tn
into four different
parts
in such a way that
delta t 1
each one of these
are the various intervals which we are
going to consider
and each one is
equal to
t n by four
okay
let's try to have a look what we have
done so far
i'll
try to
sketch
this
then this is your
this is your total
field
this is the upstream and
the downstream end
okay
i
say that this is the root zone depth
which you are interested in
irrigating
fine
and
this rules on depth
the total time taken
you are divided in when you are trying
to consider what will happen each time
in towel
which you have considered
each one is equal to one-fourth
the total time requirement
so if that is the case
let's look at that what will be the
the depth of
water infiltrated in the first time
interval
the first time interval
is delta t1
that proof infiltration
as
if i say that
in general
the depth of infiltration if you want to
take in any one interval
will be a function of
what is the
the initial depth in the soil
and what is the depth in filtered during
this time interval
so if
y i
is
the
infiltration during that
uh or the at the end of the interval
and y naught is the infiltration which
was already available
in the beginning
then during that interval you have the
the increment depth into the left of
infiltration is delta y i
so
similarly
uh the depth of
soil which will become
wet
which we'll
call as
delta z
one
you can write because we are we are
saying that this is our total z
this root zone is the
red which we have which we are
considered
this is the total depth
so in the first interval
this will be the
the
depth of soil which will be vectored
in the very first interval
if we assume that
zero to start with
let's make an assumption that z zero is
if it is known you can take that value
but if it is not known then
if it is it was totally dry you can
always take it to be zero not a very
appropriate assumption so once you
assume this
you also need the value of alpha
to be used in that equation the caustic
of equation
let's assume that the value of alpha is
also known
just for
the present
problem let's take this to be 0.5
then if these two things are known
then the very first interval delta t one
you can write this
delta z1
is equal to z2 minus
sorry is that
1 minus zero
and z1 is nothing but
you have said that
0.5
minus 0 in this present case
this is nothing but
z1
okay
so in this particular case if
this is
delta
red one
i can similarly write
the expressions for
other intervals
or delta t2
time interval
i will find out
what will be
delta z2
as z2 minus z1
okay
now z1 is nothing but
this much depth
isn't it
this is z1
is equal to delta z1
so to find out the next depth
i am trying to
reduce this
led to minus the previous step which has
been considered earlier
and the previous interval
so
z2 minus z1
which will be
equal to
k dash
into
t2
to the power
0.5
minus
delta z1
because that one is equal to delta that
one
now t2 is
2 times t1
okay
so if you
substitute that
your z2 will be
k dash
into
t1
to the power 0.5
into 2 to the power
0.5
minus delta z1 which is nothing but
delta z1 this part is defined r1
into
two to the power point five
minus
one
okay
similarly
you can write the
the other
forms also
delta z3
will be
delta z1
and 2 3 to the power 0.5 minus
2 to the power 0.5
and
so on
after that 5 will be
5 to the power 0.5 minus
4 to the power
0.5
so this general relationship can be
established
and if we plot this
onto this
you will find that
at the end of
t is equal to 1
this will be there
the simple general trend if we take that
this is a linear variation
you can
find that over the length of the field
this would be the variation which will
be encountered
because of the fact that the water is
moving from the upstream into the
downstream end
and the water is taking
one-fourth the time since the time is
equal to the time to reach the
downstream end when the water will reach
just the downstream end
the infiltration will be minimum there
similarly
the
other
segment
you'll find that the
side of the segment the depth of
infiltration will keep on reducing
that is what
you will see in the relationship
and in each case
this will be the
the trend
of the
the infiltration for each of the
the smaller segment
for example this is for t is equal to
d is equal to 3
d is equal to 4
and if you go beyond this
if you go beyond this
take another
segment
you will find
but in this
this is 40 is equal to
5 though you have gone beyond the roots
under
these
equations you
if you just analyze these equations you
will find that this trend will be shown
each successive
z
or delta z
which is lower down we'll be having
smaller and smaller depth
and that is quite understandable because
we have been studying this so far
that what happens uh when you go
when you have the infiltration for a
longer period so that is what is
reflected here
that the initial infiltration will be at
a higher rate the later infiltration
will be at a lower rate
now if you want to
satisfy the
the downstream end of the field also
you will have to provide
the water beyond the stools on depth
that means for an additional
time period
only then
this component the the lower part of the
field can also be
satisfied or in other words what you can
say is that
if you want to satisfy the needs of the
downstream and also you have to ensure
that at least the water should be
available there for tn time
what is the net
time for which the
infiltration should take place so that
to get the achieve the
net irrigation requirement
okay
so that is what
you will you can write in the form that
to infiltrate
depth yn
into the
lower end
of the field
there should be opportunity time
at the lower end
also equal to tn
okay
but we also know that t4 is
equal to how much 4 times t1
and correspondingly
z4 is
k dash
4 t1
or
delta z1
and 2 4 to the power 0.5
the same thing
so to achieve this
the infiltration opportunity at the
in order to achieve this requirement
the opportunity time
at the upstream end
has to be
d five
which is equal to
t n plus
t n by four
r is also equal to 5 times t1
and
the corresponding
z5 is
delta z1 into
5 to the power 0.5
as we have done here the same thing
okay
now if
that is what we have plotted here also
this this is basically the same thing
which we have plotted that if you want
what will happen at t is equal to 5
so that is what we have plotted already
here
now
we'll define two quantities
which are very important quantities for
our subsequent analysis and
the design purpose we can utilize these
the first is that if you want to know
the average
depth
of
soil which has been wet
by
depoculation
will be there at
average depth of soil
is basically
this part
this portion
which i can mark here
this is the deep percolation
which
could have been avoided
but since we wanted to
take care of the
downstream
areas
we have indulged in this
departure
so this deep percolation
if you want to know that how much
depopulation you have indulged into
you can
express that as
delta z 5 by
that's the average
the population
delta 5 is the
maximum deep percolation
if if we assume that this relationship
is linear
and is varying from delta five
on the upstream and to the zero level at
the downstream end then
we can say the average deep percolation
is delta 5 by
which
can also be written as
z5 minus
z4 by 2
because delta
delta 5 is nothing but
z5 is the absolute value
of the total depth
up to that level
and z4 is the depth
up to the root zone level up the
upstream end
let me
let me say that
this is
delta
z2
the next one is
i'll charge that 3
this is
delta z 4
and
that does that 5.
okay these are the initial values
but for each one this is the
z1 up to this
up to the next one is z2
z3 is at 4
and that 5
so you can
you can
use it either way this is z5 minus z4
that's what is detailed at 5
by 2 that is also you can write so this
in fact is nothing but
you can write this
this in
the general form
minus 4
to the power 0.5
into delta z 1
by
2.
okay
this is one
which gives you that what is the average
deep percolation
and if you want to find out
the
average
depth of soil
which has been wet
then you can express that as
z 4 plus
that five by two
so the total depth which has been wet
was the average value of that is the
average of the
the two extremes on one side is z five
and the side is z
so the average of that
will give you the
total depth which has been wet
this you can
also express as
4 to the point
5 plus
to the power of
okay
now if you take the
ratio of these two quantities
the
ratio
of average
depth of deep population
to
average
depth of wet soil
you can
write this as that
alternate five by two by
that four plus
z five
by two
which is
five to the power point five minus four
to the power point five
by
five to the power point five plus
four to the power point
five
and
z delta that one is cancelled out
so this is the
ratio
which
is and this particular case
is point
zero five six
now in this
in this specific case
what it amounts to is
you can
now formulate
that if
the
time of advance
dt
as one fourth
the tn
is one for the net infiltration time tn
and
for alpha
of 0.5
the average depth of
the percolation
as
5.6 percent
okay
this is only one
one instance which has been analyzed
similarly
there are
many other instances which have been
analyzed by taking different values of
alpha
which means that
by taking different characteristics of
the soil
and
by
taking different
fvr
ratios which is the
fractional advance ratio
this ratio
dt by tn
we call it as
far
or
fractional
advance
ratio
so if these are known
then you can
you can formulate the relationships
which can be used subsequently for your
analysis
and i'll show you some
values of the table which have been
which has been provided through the
similar analysis which we have done just
now
this table looks like this i'll just
pick up some of the
the values out of this table
so that you can get a feel of
this table
gives the
expected percentage
of deep population
and
on this side you have
the fractional advance ratio far
here
you have the alpha values for different
soils
maybe ranging from
point one two
point nine
for a
fire ratio of
one
or you can write it as t
that means the time of opportunity is
same as the time taken by the
the advanced curve to reach the
downstream end
you will have
the values
you can look at the order of magnitude
of these
values that how much
if you have
this parameters
fixed in such a way that your advance
curve or the time taken to reach for the
advanced curve to reach the downstream
end
is equal to the opportunity time
uh requirement
for the knight infiltration to take
place
you will incur a lot of losses
and those losses will also vary from
soil to soil
the soil as a function of alpha
so
if your
alpha is increasing
the deep population losses are also
increasing let's take another
sample of
when you have t by 4
out of which we have analyzed only one
but for the others
for example when alpha is point one and
you have a ratio of t by four
in this particular case
the
depopulation losses will be one point
one percent
2.2 percent 3.3 4.5
5.6 that is what we have analyzed for
alpha is equal to 0.5
and for
a fair ratio of d by four or one by four
and
six point seven some point eight
point nine and ten percent
let's take the
other extreme of t by 10
that means you are
you are
flooding the total
length
in a very short period
that's where far ratio is t by 10
so in this particular case
your
the percolation losses will be still
smaller
this table now
can be
utilized
for picking up some of the
parameters
you can find out that
if
you want to accept
only the deep
population losses of a
specific range
you don't want
the depopulation losses to be more than
10 percent
or more than five percent
and you know what is the type of soil
which is the prevailing type of soil
you can pick up that alpha
and you can find out what is the the
most
preferable fpr ratio
which is which can be utilized
and
that can give you some indication
towards
what should be the
the time
of allegation
should be selected
and what will be the
the time of
accordingly the time of infiltration
which will be available
is not is not dependent on only these
things it will also be dependent on then
which stream size you will be picking up
what are the other
other parameters of the field what is
the grade all those things we have not
considered so far this is only
the starting
the
those parameters which are independent
of
the other
aspects of the field they are only
giving you the relationship between
the
soil type
which is through alpha
and
the advanced time
which is again dependent on the soil
type to solve a certain extent
and all these
relationships can be utilized to start
your
design
concentrations looking at which are the
most
suitable parameters which you should be
start with
okay
so this analysis is as i had mentioned
in the beginning that this not
only concerned with
the forward education
it is as a general purpose analysis
which can be made use of
and
all the surface irrigation
methods
next we'll
try to
now
start looking at the furrow irrigation
method in particular
first of all we'll try to
look at those relationships which are
obtained through experience
through
field
trials
so these relationships
which are based on
and
field trials
these relationships are
very important
in the absence of detailed data because
you can also use the hydraulic
relationships which are more
exact
but many a time you will find that
the
required data is not available
so you have to
you have to start at least looking at
the designs with some
some indicators which are available
and
since this is a very important area all
over the world
there are word organizations
like fu which have compiled this
information and made it available in
many reports
where is easily available where people
have come out with
under different conditions what will be
the
the limiting
design parameters
from various concentrations and we have
already considered in the case of border
irrigation also
the consideration the major
concentrations
are
of the
things like
that the stream sizes shouldn't be
erosive
you shouldn't create problems for your
uh
fields
then
there's one consideration the other is
that your efficiencies should be
reasonable as with efficiencies
so that
will be basically dictated by
what sizes you will choose will be the
combination of discharge the stream size
the size of the field
with respect to the soil type and with
respect to the
slopes the prevailing grades
when you look at the grades
there again you have to look at
are those grades excessive
which can create problems of erosion
are those grades very flat which can
also create problems of
the
drainage
so they are
they know
specific uh rules and regulations which
are applicable
all over other places you will have to
look at the climate
you have to look at
as a technical area
as it a
a red area
the rules will be different from the
for the similar soils but if the area is
humid on one extreme
and the other extreme of the area is
arid you might have to choose different
parameters
for example
let's assume that it is a
humid area
in the case of humid areas
you will have lot of rainfall occurring
and that too
the intensity of the infall will be very
high
if you go in for
slopes
which are
steep slopes
maybe that
during the irrigation time you can
control those
those steam sizes you can control the
rate of application of water but what
will happen when the rain will occur
there won't be any control
at that time
the slopes which are prevailing in the
fields they will remain there
so when the rain water will be
generated
the surface runoff will be generated
that will create havoc
they'll create
lot of erosion and all your your
fields
might be distorted it might be
divided of all the fertile land which
was there it might
damage the crop all together so all
those things are possible so
when you look at
those
recommended parameters you will have to
take into consideration many other
conditions which are beyond the
irrigation conditions
these things are very important
and we'll uh
we'll look at all these
these
relationships which have been formulated
on the basis of
the
experience of the farmer as farmer might
not be
having
the scientific explanations of all these
practices which he has been
indulging into
but
through the experience through the
the common sense he has arrived at some
of the combinations which are which are
very scientific
which are very realistic
and those things have also been taken
into consideration when the various
researchers have looked into all these
various possible
details of these parameters and they
have taken
into confidence or into consideration
all those
those experiences of the local farmers
and those have also been
brought out in all those publications
wherever possible
along with that the other
are based on the experimentation
which for example in the case of border
regression we had seen that how we can
do the evaluation
runs so through those evaluation runs
you keep on taking the observations and
then you analyze those
those data and come out with the
recommended procedures
for example in the case of
the inversion
you run those
stream sizes
in the fields and see that how much
erosion is taking place
you find out which are the stream
charges which are
limiting steam sizes beyond which if you
increase the stream size for those
specific type of slides under those
slopes
you will have the erosion problem so
that is how you collect the data and you
make the recommendations
all those things we will
discuss in the next class
and along with that we'll also look at
the hydraulic
relationships which have been formulated
on the basis of the hydraulic principles
and they can be used for the design
wherever those data the required data
are available okay
any question at this stage
thank you
[Music]
you